so we have these two parallel lines line
segment a b and line segment c d they
are parallel i should say they're
parallel line segments and then we have
these transversals that go across them
so you have this transversal bc right
over here and you have this transversal
a d and what this diagram tells us is
that the distance between a and e this
little hash mark says that this line
segment is the same distance as the
distance between e and d or another way
to think about it is that point e
point e is at the midpoint or is the
midpoint of line segment a d and what i
want to think about in this video is is
point e also the midpoint of line
segment bc so we are this is the
question right over here
so is
is e
the midpoint
of
of line segment bc
and you can imagine based on a lot of
the videos we've been seeing lately
maybe it has something to do with
congruent triangles so let's see if we
can set up some congruency relationship
between the two obvious triangles in
this diagram we have this triangle up
here on the left and we have this
diagram down here this one kind of looks
like it's pointing up this one looks
like it's pointing down
so there's a bunch of things we know
about vertical angles and and angles of
transversals the most obvious one is
that we have this vertical we have we
know that angle a e b
is going to be congruent or its measure
is going to be equal to the measure of
angle c e d
so we know
we know that angle a e b
angle a e b
is going to be congruent
a e b is going to be congruent to angle
d e c
to congruent to angle d
e c which really just means they have
the exact same measure and we know that
we know that because they are vertical
angles
vertical
they are vertical
they are vertical angles
now we also know we know that a b and c
d are parallel so this line right over
here this is transversal so we know for
example there's actually several ways
that we can do this problem
but we know that this is a transversal
and there's a couple of ways to think
about it right over here so let me just
continue the transversal so we get to
see all of the different angles you
could say
you could say that this angle
this angle right here angle a b
angle a b e so this is its measure right
over here you could say that it is the
alternate interior angle to angle ecd to
this angle right over there and if you
didn't just if that didn't jump out of
you you would say that the corresponding
angle to this one right over here is
this angle right up here if you were to
continue this line off a little bit
these are the corresponding angles and
then this one is vertical but either way
angle a e b let me write this down
angle sorry angle a b e let me be clear
careful angle a
b
e
is going to be congruent to angle so
that's a b e is congruent to angle d c e
it's congruent to angle d
c e and we could say because it's
alternate interior angles
alternate
i'll just write a little code here so
alt
interior
alt interior
angles
and then we have an interesting
relationship we have an angle congruent
to an angle another angle congruent to
an angle and then the next side is
congruent to the next side over here so
pink green side pink green side so we
can employ
aas angle angle side and it's in the
right order so now we know that triangle
we have to make sure that we get the
letters right here that we have the
right corresponding vertices we can say
that triangle
triangle aeb triangle a
e actually let me start with the angle
just to make it interesting angle b e a
so we're starting with the magenta angle
going to the green angle and then going
to the one that we haven't labeled so
angle
b
e a
we can say is congruent to angle we
start with the magenta vertices c
go to the center e
and then go to the unlabeled one d and
we know this because of angle angle side
and all of the and they correspond to
each other magenta green side magenta
green side they're all congruent so this
is from
a
a s
and then if we know that they are
congruent then that means corresponding
sides are congruent so then
so then we know that this side so we
know these two triangles are congruent
so that means that their corresponding
sides are congruent so then we know that
length of be that we know that b e
the length of that segment be is going
to be equal and that's the segment
that's between the magenta and the green
angles the corresponding side is side ce
between the magenta and the green angles
is equal to ce
and this just comes out of the previous
statement if we number them that's one
that's two and that's three and so that
is comes out of statement 3 and so we
have proven us e is the midpoint of bc
it comes straight out of the fact that b
e is equal to c e so i can mark this off
with hash this line segment right over
here is congruent to this line segment
right over here because we know that
those two triangles are congruent and
i've inadvertently right here done a
little two column proof
this over here on the left hand side is
my statement
statement
statement and then on the right hand
side i gave
i gave my
i gave my reason and and we're done